Here's the answer.
The process of filling out
the table was rather mechanical, so
I won't walk through that step.
We end up with a cost of 3.5, so
that must have come from this neighbor,
here, which also has a value of 3.5.
Diagonal steps like this correspond
to matching the two letters.
So we write down that alignment here.
Next we have 3.5, which could've come
from either these two neighbors here.
Let's choose this one for now,
that corresponds to leaving w unmatched.
So we'll write that
down in our alignment.
Next we have a cost of 2.5,
which must have come from this north
west neighbor here, who has a cost one
and that corresponds to matching these
two characters together o and n.
Then we have a cost one which must have
come from this north west neighbor so
these ends get matched.
Again we have a cost of one and
since u doesn't match s this must
have come from the west neighbor.
Meaning that u is left unmatched and
we can write that down like so.
And, lastly,
the s's must be matched together.
Often there will be more than
one path through the grid.
In this example there was some
ambiguity at this step here.
Instead of skipping w,
I could have matched it with n and
then we could have left the o unmatched.
And that would of left us with
this alignment here which
has the same minimum cost.